foreign
[Music]
excited to be nominated you're freaking
out
I've already uh accomplished everything
I wanted to accomplish by being here
how's my mother look good is it good it
was all business in the front and party
in the back for Blake in the early 2000s
and of course this 29 year old was
always cracking jokes you are nominated
I got nominated for best rap song yeah
right greatest rap song of all time
actually
sure we love Blake's two decades of
music
but we also love the way he's always
teasing his Hollywood PALS like Luke
Bryan I love Luke like a brother he's
just dumb and the world got to
experience Blake's humor firsthand when
the voice debuted back in 2011. well you
know Carson was saying earlier that he
loves this show because really ugly
people even have a chance to make it he
loves that about this show no I agree
with you because no point at me I'm like
I know you've been so so super busy new
record coming out I wanted to know will
there ever be an Adam Levine guest spot
on this God no you wanna hear something
I reached out to Blake a couple months
ago
said hey man I want to do a song and he
didn't even write it back this the
singing competition not only brought us
Blake's Bromance with Adam Levine but
also the most unexpected romance with
Gwen Stefani I'm thankful for Gwen for
tons of reasons but mostly just because
she makes us all look a whole lot better
on that show you're incredible I would
love to coach you
her microphone how has Blake helped you
um
my entire life he just makes me laugh
and smile and just it's just like the
greatest guy how do you not put a ring
on that woman's finger I'm just throwing
that out there that's just me no room I
know after dating for five years Blake
got down on one knee and in July of 2021
they said I do in Blake's home state of
Oklahoma when did you know Gwen was the
one for you
uh it didn't take long you know I had
known Gwen uh from working with her on
The Voice both of our Lives had
basically Fallen completely apart it
happened to both of us at the same time
and we bonded over that so somewhere in
that time of you know Darkness it was
this was it ended up being the greatest
moment of my life
[Applause]
[Music]
you seem to be in this easy breezy Blake
era how would you describe this chapter
in your life look I love music I love
the voice I love all the cool things I
get to do with my job but those things
are at all take a back seat now to Gwen
and the kids and it's just a new phase
of my life that new phase includes
taking a step away from his red coach's
chair after his 23rd season this spring
what is to come what's the game plan you
know for me I want to keep my music side
of what I do alive from now until
they they fire me fans fire me you know
I mean the TV stuff's fun and it's been
great for me and it's actually helped
pour over into my music you know I've
pulled an audience from TV that maybe
didn't even know who I was but at the
end of the day having songs on the radio
and and being able to go out and tour
and play and that's what I that's what I
do I'm a country singer
[Music]